un salon lounge aménager trois bureaux
trois salles de réunion à saint cyr
l'école aéro fils propose différents
espaces depuis le 27 sept ans ils
permettent d'offrir des services variés
à sa clientèle haute où on a trois
salles de réunion donc une petite salle
de six à huit personnes
une deuxième salle qui peut aller
jusqu'à 20 personnes et une troisième
que peut aller jusqu'à 30 90 parce 19
personnes en conférence tant que jeune
entreprise on peut pas se permettre à
nous payer des locaux et appuyer en
loyer pour un bureau donc c'est plus
sympathique à louer un espace comme
celui-ci éviter les longs déplacements
pour privilégier le télétravail l'offre
semble adapté à la période de
restrictions sanitaires que nous
traversons chiant en télétravail depuis
novembre et ça dure un peu et parfois on
a envie de changer de sortir un peu de
chez ça c'est si on continue à 30
personnes mais que d aller dans un
espace beaucoup plus de monde et éviter
notamment les transports c'est pas
évident tout simplement de travailler
chez soi parce qu on est tout le temps
amené à faire les tâches ménagères et
travailler en même temps c'est pas
évident donc si bien aéro fille ceci
parce que on peut accueillir à des
clients tout simplement aéro fils
propose également des cours de yoga pour
allier travail et bien-être ainsi qu'un
cours de salsa le vendredi soir les
tarifs pour les espaces de travail
aménagés varient de 15 euros la
demi-journée à 300 euros pour le forfait
mensuel